i need you to put your right foot in
front of your left foot with your right
heel touch your left toe
feet in a straight line and your hands
down by your sides i need you to stay in
that position until i give you all the
instructions you understand
right and you just stay in that position
until i give you all the instructions
you understand
all right when i tell you to you're
going to take a series of nine
heel to toe steps hands down by your
sides
looking down your feet
counting your steps out loud when you
get to nine you're gonna leave your
front foot or your lead foot planted
take a series of small steps safe turn
yourself around and you're gonna take
nine heel to toe steps back so let's go
under arrest for dui all right
who's that whose idea is this
75 northbound heading up the north side
drive ramp the blackmail
blue hat
jeans
short sleeve shirt star music try and
cut them off on northside drive
[Applause]
[Applause]
10 24 he just jumped over the ramp he
landed jesus radio it's like a 60-foot
drop
he's down on the ground
i can't even tell you where he's at or
where he's gonna come out
all right
[Applause]
back here
right here
[Music]
there's a building over here
[Applause]
somebody is with the vehicle correct i
know there's three people here